Could it be that the most dangerous region
in the world is trying to improve itself?
Imagine that you’re sitting quietly at a
restaurant or cafeteria and, suddenly, you
begin to hear gunshots a few meters away.
You’d choose an empty stomach and opt for
a quick escape, wouldn’t you?
Well, unfortunately these kinds of situations
are common in many Central American cities.
Cities where security is noticeable for its
absence.
In 2018, 42 of the 50 most violent cities
in the world were in Latin America, and of
these, two were in Honduras, one in Guatemala
and one in El Salvador.
In 2017 alone, more than 14,500 homicides
were registered in Central America.
The vast majority, more than 90% of them,
happened in three countries known as the Northern
Triangle: El Salvador, Honduras and Guatemala.
Chilling, to say the least.
So why is violence so common in this part
of the world?
What is driving these high crime rates?
Has Central America always been a violent
region?
Let’s find out.
(INTRO)
Here’s a question for you: Have you ever
noticed how curious the map of the American
continent is?
Just look at it for a second, Central America
is a bridge between South America and North
America.
And not only metaphorically, but also literally.
And this has consequences:
The fact that Central America is a bridge
has turned it into the largest illicit goods
highway in the world.
For goods produced in South America.
We’re mostly talking about cocaine.
No less than 90% of all the cocaine that enters
the United States, the world's largest market
for the drug, passes through Central America.
But don’t think this is the only illegal
activity based there.
Not at all.
Human trafficking; trafficking of illegal
immigrants and minors, is also booming in
this region.
And as you can imagine, all of these activities
go hand in hand with organized crime; criminal
organizations that control, manage and fight
each other for dominance of all these businesses.
We’re talking about a huge industry, and
a highly structured one: with managers, administrators,
lawyers, corporate advisors, diversification,
investment strategies, etc.
An industry that is increasingly becoming
involved in developing a presence in Central
America.
Check it out.
(AUDIO: Mexican cartels are moving 90% of
their activities to Central America, according
to research.
- Agencia EFE)
The increasing pressure from the state in
Mexico in recent years has made this type
of mafia want to settle in countries with
weaker and less vigilant governments.
And you know what?
The truth is that these groups, these macro-crime
companies have managed to take over much of
Central America.
(MEXICO, CRIME EXPORTER TO CENTRAL AMERICA)
Mexico – or rather the Mexican cartels – are
slowly becoming the leaders, the biggest drug
business owners in Latin America.
Of course, they’ve been competing with Colombian
groups for quite some time.
The Mexican cartels already control the majority
of the main routes for transporting illegal
goods.
And that pretty much means controlling all
of Central America.
Now, let's put ourselves in the shoes of these
great bosses for a second.
Imagine that you’re one of them.
What’s the fastest way to control the Central
American territory?
How can you settle in and dominate this region?
Exactly, a good option would be to establish
alliances with the native criminal groups,
those that were there before you.
Groups that have the necessary infrastructure,
contacts and knowledge of the territory that
you need.
We’re talking about groups that have a single
philosophy: work with whoever gives you the
most cash.
This is hardly surprising.
We all know the power of the dollar.
But how and why did Central America become
so ripe for exploitation by the Mexican drug
traffickers?
To understand that we need to go back to the
90s.
You see, the key moment, when the players
changed, happened between 1991 and 1993, when
the Medellín Cartel suffered its greatest
defeat.
Pablo Escobar’s fall, as well as that of
the cartel’s main bosses, also meant losing
the huge influence and power they had in Central
America, which they’d gained thanks to their
alliances with local groups, who worked directly
for them.
And that was the Mexican groups’ great window
of opportunity, which of course they took
advantage of by storming into Central America
with the objective of completely controlling
that important bridge, which connects the
production centers with the consumption centers.
But surely some of you may be thinking.
Just a second, Simon, there are several different
cartels in Mexico, didn’t that pose a problem?
Yes, indeed, it did.
After the Mexicans arrived, Central America
became a kind of battlefield between the different
Mexican cartels who fought to control the
transport routes.
And that’s precisely one of the reasons
that violence in Central America increased
dramatically until finally each cartel claimed
their own niche territory.
You could say that Mexican cartels became
major exporters of violence and crime to their
southern neighbors.
Check out the case of Honduras for example.
(CHART)
You see, the power struggles between Mexican
cartels and local groups to increase their
influence and gain control of the business
explain much of the increased crime during
those years.
Now, let's put all big numbers aside.
Let's focus on the streets.
How exactly do all these battles between cartels
and Central American criminal groups affect
the safety of regular citizens?
Listen up.
(WHEN VIOLENCE DOESN’T FIND AN ENEMY)
We’ve already showed you that the Central
American North Triangle has the highest crime
rates in the world.
That’s why we ask an essential question,
is there a solution?
What does the region need to achieve social
peace?
Well, the truth is that this goal seems very,
very complicated, why?
Check this out…
(AUDIO: Honduran President’s Brother Is
Found Guilty of Drug Trafficking.
- The New York Times)
(AUDIO: Honduran President Is Accused of Drug
Conspiracy.
Prosecutors say drug proceeds were allegedly
used to support Honduran President Juan Orlando
Hernández’s 2013 election WSJ)
(AUDIO: Son of ex-Honduran president Porfirio
Lobo gets 24 years for U.S. drug charge.
Reuters)
(AUDIO: Former El Salvador President Saca
gets two-year prison term for bribery.
- Reuters)
Against such a backdrop of corruption, institutionalized
drug-trafficking and other despicable actions,
who would put up their hand to fight crime?
Especially if crime itself is in charge!
If the highest spheres of power in Central
America have such close ties, very close,
with the great criminals, how on earth is
anyone going to fight them?
And it’s not that they can’t, but that
they don’t want to.
It’s a matter of incentives.
No one, absolutely no one wants to kill the
goose that lays the golden eggs.
However, just a second.
Because despite this harsh reality, the truth
is that in recent years, Central America has
experienced a gradual reduction in homicide
rates.
This has led many politicians to stand up.
Of course, in many cases, it wasn’t thanks
to the government, but in spite of it.
Let's take a look at El Salvador.
For example, in El Salvador in 2018, they
had 15% fewer homicides than in the previous
year, but even so, it was still a very high
number: 3,340 homicides in one year in a country
of less than six and a half million inhabitants.
El Salvador is the country with the highest
homicide rate in the most dangerous region
on the planet.
So we could say it’s the most dangerous
country in the world.
But even though the country has encouraged
it, the truth is that this history of violence
comes from way back, long before the Mexican
cartels ever set foot in Central America.
We’ve talked about them for a while on VisualPolitik.
The Maras are dangerous criminal gang member
groups, many based in Los Angeles, that are
dedicated mainly to drug and weapons trafficking,
money laundering, immigrant trafficking and
prostitution.
Since the 1960s, they’ve been one of El
Salvador’s greatest security challenges.
The Mara Salvatrucha or MS13 and Barrio 18
are the two main branches which, as expected,
often fight each other, and have been trying
to control the Salvadoran territory for many
years in order to better carry out their illegal
activities.
It has been this fight over the territory
that has spread pain and suffering all over
El Salvador.
And of course, these maras are still fully
active.
So why is it that crime has decreased in recent
years?
Well... take a look at this...
(AUDIO: Drug traffickers use maras and street
gangs to dominate Central America.
- Excelsior)
Yes, as you can see, paradoxically this alliance
could explain much of the reduction in homicides.
Why?
Well...
The answer is complex, but simplifying it
a bit, we could say that currently the maras
are acting as branches of the most powerful
Mexican cartels, such as the Sinaloa Cartel
or Los Zetas.
Interestingly, this alliance could be causing
part of these gangs’ forces to be operating
in wider fields, protecting the Mexican cartels’
activities, and thus moving them away from
the streets.
Let's say there are bigger businesses than
extorting money from the corner store.
And that’s not the only change.
In addition, Mexican cartels have noticed
that the Maras are tremendously effective
in controlling cities and infusing the greatest
possible terror.
So, they are recruiting troops and moving
to Mexico to support their activities and
to train their own people.
Basically they are enlisting them.
That way, Mexicans have introduced the maras
into the large-scale international drug trafficking
business.
But how exactly are the gangs helping the
Mexican cartels?
Well, obviously not for the common good.
They are teaching them the most horrible,
cruel and ruthless ways of treating their
adversaries.
These are techniques they are moving to and
implementing in Mexico itself.
I think that now you can understand better
why crime has decreased in recent years.
And yes, unfortunately, it has had little
to do with governments or with the US’s
plan for Central America, and more with the
dynamics of the crime industry.
Surely at this point many may be thinking
that this is getting out of hand, right?
Maras and cartels collaborating, governments
bought by and backing criminal interests,
ineffective and corrupt security forces, bribed
courts...
Against such a backdrop, do you think that
El Salvador and Central America in general
have any chance to escape this vicious circle?
What can Salvadorans do to stop being the
most dangerous country in the world?
Well, I'm sorry to say that it doesn't look
like an easy task.
But who knows, perhaps the arrival of this
man, who’s very well-known for leading his
government through tweets, can make a step
forward by showing that one of the problems
of Central America, and perhaps the most important
one, is that there’s a lack of political
will.
(AUDIO: Nayib Bukele, an Outsider Candidate,
Claims Victory in El Salvador Election.
- The New York Times)
[TEXT: And here, on June 1st, we’ll build
the best government in our country’s history.]
Bukele came to power early in 2019 with the
key promise of making El Salvador a safer
and less corrupt country.
Will he achieve it?
Only time will tell, but for now, it looks
like he’s taking decisive steps to do so.
Of course, with Latin American politicians...
Well, no one ever knows.
In this region the forecasts, especially if
they’re optimistic, aren’t worth very
much.
(AUDIO: El Salvador launches anti-corruption
commission, inspired by Guatemala.
- Reuters)
And be careful because corruption isn’t
a minor problem.
In this region, fighting corruption is a necessary
step to break the link between power and crime.
Well, having reached this point, we’ve seen
why politicians can’t take the credit, even
if homicide rates are decreasing; we’ve
seen that nowadays there’s little room for
hope in Honduras and that El Salvador could
be facing a great opportunity for real change.
However, in this delicate balance of crime
and power we need to include another Central
American country.
A country that isn’t part of the Northern
Triangle, but which has recently seen a dramatic
increase in violence.
In many cases, a very different violence,
because drug-trafficking isn’t the only
disease that plagues Central America.
Listen up.
[TEXT: I want them to leave the country.
I want them to go to jail.]
(NICARAGUA, THE END OF A DREAM?)
We’ve talked about this in several videos.
In Nicaragua there’s a phenomenon that doesn’t
happen in many other Latin American countries,
that is the use of violence as a form of political
control.
It’s a scenario similar to the one found
in Venezuela, and which has suddenly ended
the myth that Nicaragua was the exception;
the only safe country in the most dangerous
region in the world.
For example, in 2017 Nicaragua only had seven
homicides per 100,000 inhabitants, while at
the same time in Honduras it was 40, it was
51 in El Salvador and 28 in Guatemala.
The difference is remarkable, but that doesn’t
really mean Nicaragua is a safe place to live.
Time has shown us that.
The Sandinista National Liberation Front,
the ruling party, has completely penetrated
the state power agencies, politicizing them
by getting like-minded people into key positions
and using true paramilitary groups to repress
the population.
Nicaraguan tyrant Daniel Ortega has literally
begun employing thugs to do the dirtiest work
in the name of the police and the army during
the protests.
And yes, from a political and institutional
point of view, this is one of the worst decisions
a leader can make.
(AUDIO: Alarm rises for a wave of crimes with
viciousness that bear the seal of the paramilitaries
of Daniel Ortega in Nicaragua.
- Infobae)
(AUDIO: In 2018, violence rates skyrocketed
through the brutal repression of civil protesters
by President Daniel Ortega's regime.
InsightCrime)
Because as soon as a government begins using
irregular force to repress the masses, they
create conditions that legalize and normalize
violence and give impunity at a general level.
You could say the floodgates of crime are
opened with the first blow.
We’ve seen it in Venezuela and we’re starting
to see it in Nicaragua.
Anyway, as you can see, crime, corruption
and a lack of safety are the great evils that
are hanging over Central America.
In many cases, if not in all, this is happening
with the approval and complicity of the political
powers.
We wanted to make this video to better show
you exactly what is happening in this region
of the world, the most dangerous region on
the planet, in terms of violence.
As well as to show what is hiding behind the
decreasing number of homicides that have been
seen in recent years.
So, now, it’s your turn:
Do you think that safety in Central America
is an impossible dream?
Can the region really get rid of the curse
of drug-trafficking and organized crime?
Leave your answers in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.